sacré contraste au beau milieu de la
sacro sainte fête de jeanne d'arc si
institutionnelle depuis huit ans le set
électro fait bouger des dizaines de
milliers dans les années chaque set mais
bay vénérable défilé et pendant 7 ans
set électro adressé sa scène place de la
loire or comme son nom l'indiqué ce bel
endroit est situé le long du fleuve
c'est ce qui en fait son charme son
charme et sa dangerosité comme la mairie
l'a compris lorsqu une crue a failli
l'obligé à annuler la fête
ce fut l'occasion d'une prise de
conscience vous savez les mouvements de
foule ça peut aller très vite je vous
étiez partenaires d'ailleurs de
certaines soirées et bien un mouvement
de foule s'est très vite même des
barrières vauban mise en double vous
savez ça n'a qu'une résistance là on
peut difficilement résister contre une
pression humaine et cette année deux
sets électro va donc déménagé plus que
sur le parvis du théâtre d'orléans
nous avions quatre autres sites et celui
ci a été retenu à côté d'un lieu
culturel effectivement qui donne de la
place énormément pour la scène
et puis également pour le public qui
pourra se répartir entre le début de
l'avenue
et puis la rue par sa masse en place de
lois relais qui était fermée à la
circulation pendant quatre jours ceux
qui n'avaient pas de conséquences
majeures pour la circulation dans
l'agglomération et on irait tout
autrement sur cet axe majeur est ouest
qui longe le théâtre d'orléans
contrairement à l'organisation
précédente nous devions coupé à la fois
deux jours avant deux jours après la
manifestation tandis que là il y aura
peut-être un ralentissement lorsque des
camions viendront amener le matériel
mais il n'y aura pas de coupure ni avant
ni après il y aura une coupure bien
évidemment pendant la manifestation à
partir de 21h au 20h jusqu'à 1h 2h du
matin
une seule soirée sans pouvoir circuler
donc une seule soirée dans la nuit à
supporter pour les riverains qui ne
seraient pas tous adeptes de l'électro
se croyait jusqu'ici à l'abri de sombres